amis
frères et soeurs
qui peut
nous divertir mois et marraines en nous
racontant un mythe
ou une légende
[Musique]
au plus grand droit
lhermitte et un bruit chalier essayé de
porter un coup contre moi
accordez moi le plaisir de ce jeu je
porterai ce coup
[Applaudissements]
dans
un nom
une année c'est presque écoulé
ils te font le trouver n'était ce pas
juste un jeu peut-être mais il n'est pas
terminée
d'une heure a droit à aucune pitié
et de fin heureuse
pourquoi tu m'arrête est imminente
repose toi maintenant je finirai cette
quête pour toi
c'est
eq espères-tu obtenir
en affrontant tout ça
l'honneur
c'est la raison d'être de tout chevalier
tu lui prêt
[Musique]